-It's time for "Tonight Show"
Stocking Stuffers!
Here we go!
-♪ "Tonight Show"
Stocking Stuffers ♪
♪ It's "Tonight Show"
♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Every night until
Christmas break,
we're giving away an incredible
gift to every single person
in our studio audience.
You guys excited?
You guys ready for this?
Let's see what
you're taking home tonight.
Questlove, drum roll, please.
[ Drum roll ]
Tonight's Stocking Stuffer is...
a pair of Bose
QuietComfort Earbuds II!
-Yeah, Jimmy,
Bose QuietComfort Earbuds II
weren't designed with
a one-size-fits-all approach.
These next-generation
wireless earbuds
are engineered to fit you.
They personalize
the noise cancellation
and sound performance
to your ears,
so you can enjoy the world's
best noise cancellation
and uninterrupted
immersive listening
wherever you are, Jimmy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
Look at that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
This is what I'm talking about.
This is real deal.
I love this.
Oh, it's ready.
100% charged.
Enjoy your gift, everybody.